thank you do the next speaker is
ruh-huh Benjamin from Princeton in media
african-american studies
[Music]
does anybody need papers note cards or
parents for preparing questions you
think having your questions written was
very helpful
other side of the room anyone
okay hi everyone good morning this is
the first time I get to speak on a panel
with my colleague Naomi we had to come
all the way to Berkeley to do it but I'm
excited thank you so much to Cynthia and
Pat for conceiving and convening this
workshop and the Simon's Institute for
hosting all of us so let's start with a
relatively new app called citizen which
will send you real-time crime alerts
based on a curated selection of 911
calls it also offers a way for users to
report live stream and comment on
purported crimes via the app and it also
shows you incidents as red dots on a map
so you can avoid particular areas which
is a slightly less racialized version of
apps called ghetto tracker and sketch
factor which use public data to help
people avoid supposedly dangerous
neighborhoods so I'm sure some of you
are thinking what could possibly go
wrong
in the age of barbeque Becky's calling
the police on black people cooking
walking breathing out of place it turns
out that even a Stanford educated
environmental scientists living in the
Bay Area pictured here is an ambassador
of the carceral state calling the police
on a cookout at Lake Merritt it's worth
noting too that Lake Merritt that the
app citizen was originally called the
less chill named vigilante and it's
rebranding
is also moving moved away from
encouraging people to stop crime but
rather now to avoid it as one member of
the New York City Council put it quote
crime is now at historic lows in the
city but because residents are
constantly being bombarded with push
notifications of crime they believe the
city is going to hell in a handbasket
not only is this categorically false
they said it's distracting people from
very real public safety issues like
reckless driving or Rises it rising
opioid use that don't show up on that
what's most important to our discussion
I think is that citizen
and other tech fixes for social problems
are not simply about technology's impact
on society but also about how social and
political norms and values shape what
tools are imagined necessary in the
first place this dynamic is what I take
up into forthcoming books the first is
an edited volume on the carceral
dimensions of technology across a wide
range of social arenas for more
traditional sites like policing and
prisons - less obvious contexts like the
retail industry and digital economy the
second examines the interplay between
race automation and machine bias more
broadly as an extension of older forms
of racial domination in this work I'm
concerned with who and what are fixed in
place to enable innovation in science
and tech how are novel technologies
deployed and carceral approaches to
governing life well beyond the domain of
policing but also to what end do we
imagine how can transformation of our
political cultural and social norms work
towards collective forms of freedom and
how might technoscience be appropriated
and reimagined for more Liberatore ends
both of these works are wrestling in
different ways with how technology
captivates capturing bodies yes dash
cams on the front of police vehicles
recording traffic stops turn deadly as
with the arrest of Sandra bland on a
Texas Highway robot cranes reaching 30
feet in the air monitoring images and
heat signatures throughout Camden New
Jersey deepening police occupation of
impoverished neighborhoods crime
prediction algorithms labeling black
defendants higher risk than their white
counterparts reinforcing popular
stereotypes of criminality and innocence
behind the veneer of objectivity
electronic ankle monitor is wrapping
around the limbs of thousands of people
as they await trial or serve parole a
quote attractive alternative to cages
more humane and cost-effective than
jails we are told tools in this way
capture more than just people's bodies
they also capture the imagination
offering technical fixes for a wide
range of social problems electronic
tracking and location systems are
the growing suite of interventions
dubbed techno Corrections indeed these
interventions come bubble wrapped and
rhetoric about correcting not just
individuals but social disorders like
poverty and crime in the first ever
report to analyze the impact of
electronic monitoring on youth in
California we learned that amana Turing
entails a combination of onerous and
arbitrary rules that end up forcing
young people back into custody for quote
technical violations attractive fixes it
turns out produce new opportunities for
people to violate the law and thereby
new grounds for penalizing them but
perhaps this is the point as this
headline illustrates the same company
geo group that profits from locking up
immigrant families and detention centers
with ice contracts worth hundreds of
millions of dollars also profits from
their release with the increasing use of
ankle monitors which is one of many
quote alternatives to detention that
requires our sustained and critical
attention in fact I encourage more
research on the many tech fixes that
criminalize immigration which I think
can get overlooked and the focus on
building walls and detention centers
according to a Pew study the number of
devices in the u.s. increased nearly a
hundred and forty percent from 2005 to
2015 when more than 125 thousand people
were being monitored and I'm sure the
number has since grown in a recent audit
of California's gang database not only
do black and Latin X people constitute
87 percent of those listed but many of
the names turned out to be babies under
the age of one some of whom were
supposedly self-described gang members
so far no one ventures to explain how
this could have happened except to say
that some combination of zip codes and
racially coded names constitute a risk
that is prior regimes of racial
segregation and classification
facilitate tech mediated social control
which we have to remember is not limited
to obvious forms of incarceration and
punishment but entail what sociologist
karla shed rights as carceral contend
the carceral continuum that scales over
prison walls into the everyday lives of
those that are purportedly free wrapping
around hospitals school
banks humanitarian organizations
shopping malls in the digital service
economy fixes that suffocate sociality
by making someone choose whether to make
curfew or help their ailing mother to
the hospital as activist James Kilgore
describes all while paying a monthly fee
for the cost of one's shackle in this
context the distinction between those
who are bound and unbound inside and
outside of the prison wall does not
serve us because then we miss all the
ways that carceral logics and tools
penetrate everyday life a few months ago
it was reported that Cook County has
started issuing juvenile ankle monitors
that can call and record kids without
their consent and as one Chicago
fifteen-year-old who's currently being
monitored put it they give you all the
tools to bury yourself here again the
nightmare of some is the fantasy of
others so how should we understand this
duplicity of tech fixes purported
solutions that nevertheless reinforce an
even deep in existing hierarchies one
formulation that's hard to miss is the
idea of racist robots a first wave of
stories seem to be shocked at the
prospect that link what Langdon Leonard
winter terms artifacts have politics a
second wave seemed less surprised well
of course technology inherits its
creators biases and now I think we've
entered a phase of attempts to override
or address the default settings of
racist robots for better or worse and
one of the challenges we face is how to
meaningfully differentiate technologies
that are used to differentiate us the
combination of coded bias and imagined
objectivity is what I turned the Nuge
the new jim code innovation that enables
social containment while appearing fair
and more than fair than discriminatory
practices of a previous era so this riff
off of Michelle Alexander's analysis in
the new Jim Crow
considers how the reproduction of racist
forms of social control in successive
institutional forms slavery Jim Crow
ghettoization mass incarceration entails
a crucial socio technical component that
not only hides the nature of domination
but allows it to penetrate every facet
of social life under the guise of
progress this formulation as I highlight
here is direct
related to a number of other cousin
concepts by Brown Broussard Eubanks
noble noble and others the new gym code
is situated in a hybrid literature that
I think of as race critical code studies
this approach is not only concerned with
the impacts of Technology but its
production and particularly how race and
racism enter the process two works that
that illustrate this approach are one
Nobel's algorithms of oppression in
which she argues that racist and sexist
Google search results like pornographic
images returned when you type in the
phrase black girls grow out of a
corporate logic of either willful
neglect or a profit imperative that
makes money from racism and sexism in a
different vein Simone Brown examines how
the history of surveillance technologies
reflect and reproduce distorted notions
of blackness explaining that quote
surveillance is nothing new to black
folks from slave ships to slave patrols
to airport security checkpoints and stop
and frisk policing practices she points
to quote the facticity of surveillance
and black life challenging a techno
deterministic approach that only looks
at technologies impacts she argues that
instead of seeing surveillance as
something inaugurated by new
technologies to see it as ongoing is to
insist that we factor in how racism and
anti blackness undergird and sustained
the intersecting surveillances of our
present order so as we think about how
anti blackness gets encoded in and
exercised through automated systems i
want to consider for conceptual
offspring to the new jim code that I see
is falling along a spectrum engineered
inequity names those technologies that
explicitly seek to amplify social
cleavages they're what we might think of
as the most obvious less hidden
dimensions of the new jim code but even
they typically come wrapped in the
packaging of progress though the idea is
usually that in order for some people to
move forward others must be contained
default discrimination are those
inventions that tend to ignore social
cleavages and as such tend to reproduce
the default settings of race class and
gender among other axes of difference
coded exposure
examines the way that some technologies
fail to see racial difference while
others render racialized people hyper
visible and exposed to systems of
surveillance and finally techno
benevolence names those tech
developments that claim to address bias
of various sorts but may still manage to
reproduce or even deepen discrimination
in part because of the narrow way in
which fairness is defined and
operationalized so for the sake of time
I'm just going to sketch the last three
very quickly so default discrimination
includes those technologies that
reinforce inequities precisely because
designers fail to seriously attend to
the social context of their work which
includes racial domination carceral
tools that underpin the u.s. penal
system are a key feature of the new jim
code at every stage of the process from
policing sentencing imprisonment to
parole automated programs are
supplanting the traditional role of
humans Naomi all already discussed the
ProPublica study so the only thing I'll
underscore is how these risk scores
reinforce and hide racial domination by
ignoring all the ways that racism shapes
the inputs for example the survey is
given to prospective parolees to
determine how likely they are to
recidivate includes questions about
their criminal history education
employment history financial history
neighborhood characteristics among other
factors all of these variables have been
structured by racial domination from job
market discrimination to ghetto ization
the survey measures the extent to which
an individual's life has been impacted
by structural racism without ever asking
the individuals race colorblind codes
that on the surface appear better than a
bias judge or prosecutor coded exposure
names the tension between ongoing
surveillance of racialized populations
and calls for digital recognition and
inclusion the desire to literally be
seen by technology linking historical
precedents with contemporary techniques
different forms of exposure serve as a
touchstone for considering how the act
of viewing something or someone may put
the object of vision at risk
a form of skopic vulnerability central
to the experience of being racialized
what i underscore here is that it's not
only the process of being out of sight
but also in the danger of being too
centered that racialized groups are made
vulnerable in Alondra Nelson's term a
dialectic of neglect and surveillance is
at work so that being included is not
simply a positive recognition but can be
a form of unwanted exposure but not
without creative resistance as I'll come
back to in just a moment so if I had
more time I would show you a clip from
Better Off Ted in which there are all
these sensors that can't see black
people so some of you know this
short-lived TV sitcom in which the
writers parody the phenomenon of bias
technology and this episode called
racial sensitivity in it the corporation
where the show takes place installs a
new state-of-the-art system that's going
to save money they're told but employees
soon find there's a glitch in the system
that keeps it from recognizing people
with dark skin so then the show's
protagonist confronts his boss
suggesting the censors are racist she
insists otherwise the company's position
is that actually it's the opposite of
racist because it's not targeting black
people
it's just ignoring them they insist that
the worst people can call it isn't
different
in the meantime they'd like to remind
everyone to celebrate the fact that it
does see Hispanics Asians Pacific
Islanders and Jews the show brilliantly
depicts how a superficial corporate
diversity ethos prioritization of
efficiency over equity and the default
whiteness of technovic - tech tech
development work together to ensure
innovation produces containment the fact
that black employees are unable to use
elevators doors water fountains or turn
the lights on is treated as a minor
inconvenience and service to a greater
good playing off of the political
anxieties around reverse discrimination
and affirmative action the episode
titled racial sensitivity which is
usually that charge brought against
black people will call attention to
racism is a commentary on the company's
insensitivity the episode also manages
to illustrate how indifference to
blackness can be profitable until
eventually the social costs become too
high to maintain
finally some of the most interesting
developments I think are those we can
think of as techno benevolence that aims
to address bias in various ways take for
example new AI power techniques for
vetting job applicants a company called
hirevue aims to quote reduce unconscious
bias and promote diversity in the
workplace by using an AI powered system
that analyzes recorded interviews of
prospective employees it uses thousands
of data points including verbal and
nonverbal cues like facial expression
posture and vocal tone and compares job
seekers scores to those of existing top
performing employees to decide who to
flag as a desirable hire and who to
reject the sheer size of many applicant
pools and the amount of money and time
that companies pour into recruitment is
astronomical so companies like hirevue
can narrow the eligible pool at a
fraction of the time and cost and
hundreds of companies including Goldman
Sachs Hilton Unilever Unilever Red Sox
Atlanta Public School System and more
have signed on another value added
according to higher views that there's a
lot that a human interviewer misses that
AI can keep track of to quote make
data-driven talent decisions after all
the problem of employment discrimination
is widespread and well documented so the
logic goes wouldn't this be more reason
to outsource decisions to AI well a
study by a Princeton team of computer
scientists examined whether a popular
algorithm trained on human writing
online exhibited the same racially
biased tendencies that psychologists and
others have documented among humans in
particular they found that the algorithm
associated white sounding names with
Pleasant words and black sounding names
with unpleasant ones a riff off of soon
deals classic resume study and so here
we have also gender coded words and
names as Amazon learned last year when
it's hiring Algar algorithm was found
discriminating against women
nevertheless it should be clear why
technical fixes that claim to bypass
human biases are so desirable if only
there was a way to slay centuries of
racists and sexist demons with the
social justice BOTS beyond desirable
more like magical magical for employers
perhaps
looking to streamline the grueling work
of recruitment but occurs for many job
seekers whereas proponents describe a
very human-like interaction those who
are on the hunt for jobs recount a very
different experience
applicants are frustrated not only by
the lack of human contact but also
because they have no idea how they are
being evaluated and why they're
repeatedly a rejected one job seeker
described questioning every small
movement and microexpression
and feeling a heightened sense of
worthlessness because the company
couldn't even assign a person for a few
minutes and as this headline puts it
your next interview could be with a
racist robot bringing us back to that
problem space we started with it's worth
noting here that some job seekers are
already developing ways to subvert the
system by trading answers to employers
tests and creating fake applications as
informal audits of their own in fact one
HR employee for a major company
recommends slipping the words Oxford or
Cambridge into your CV and invisible
white text to pass the automated
screening in terms of a more collective
response a Federation of European trade
unions called uni global has developed a
charter of digital rights for workers
touching on automated and AiAi based
decisions to be included in bargaining
agreements closer to home in just a few
months ago senators Booker and Lyndon
and representative Yvette Clarke
introduced the algorithmic
accountability act of 2019 which
requires companies to study the
algorithms they use identify bias in
these systems and fix any discrimination
or bias they find citing complaints
against Facebook's targeted ads that
enable housing discrimination and Amazon
sexist recruiting tool one of the most
heartening developments to me is tech
industry employees themselves having
increasingly been speaking out against
the most egregious forms of corporate
collusion with sting state sanctioned
racism in the form of ice contracts and
important but limited development
perhaps we can talk about in a more
collaborative vein initiatives like data
for black lives and the Detroit
Community Technology Project offer an
even more expansive approach the former
brings people across working across a
number of agencies and organizations
together in a proactive approach to tech
justice especially at the policy level
and the latter develops and uses
technology rooted in community needs
offering support to grass root through
grassroots networks doing data justice
research including discotheques which
stands for discovering technology which
are multi media mobile neighborhood
workshop fairs that can be adapted in
other locales and I'll just mention one
of the concrete collaborations that's
grown out of data for black lives last
year several government agencies in st.
Paul Minnesota including the police
department and the public schools formed
a controversial joint powers agreement
called the innovation project giving
these agencies broad discretion to
collect and share data on young people
with the goal of developing predictive
tools to identify at-risk youth in the
city there was immediate and broad-based
backlash from the community and in 2017
a group of over 20 local organizations
formed the quote stopped the cradle to
Prison algorithm coalition data for
black lives has been providing various
forms of support to this coalition and
eventually the city of st. Paul
dissolved the agreement in favor of what
they call a community approach which was
a huge victory for activists and
community members who'd been fighting
these policies for over a year then in
terms of what I call an abolitionist
approach to the new Jim Code I also want
to mention our data bodies playbook
which introduces a set of tools for
diagnosing dealing with and healing the
injustice 'as a pervasive and punitive
data collection and data driven systems
the PlayBook contains in-depth
guidelines for facilitating workshops
and group activities plus tools tip
sheets reflection pieces and rich
stories crafted from in-depth interviews
with communities in Charlotte Detroit
and Los Angeles with the aim of
engendering power not paranoia when it
comes to technology toward that end the
late legal and critical race scholar
Derek a bell encouraged a radical
assessment of reality through creative
methods and racial reversals insisting
that to see things as they really are
you must imagine them for what they
might be which is why I think the arts
and humanities are vital part of the
conversation that we're having today one
of my favorite examples of a racial
reversal is this parody project that
begins by subverting the
tie black logics embedded in hi-tech
approaches to crime for prevention
instead of using predictive policing
techniques to forecast street crime the
white collar early warning system flips
the script by creating a heat map that
Flags city blocks where financial crimes
are likely to occur the system not only
brings the hidden but no less deadly
crimes of capitalism into view but
includes an app that alerts users when
they enter high-risk areas to encourage
citizen policing and awareness taking it
one step further the development team is
working on a facial recognition program
to flag individuals who are likely
perpetrators and the training set used
to design the algorithm includes the
profile photos of 7,000 corporate
executive executives downloaded from
LinkedIn not surprisingly the averaged
face of a criminal is white and male to
be sure creative exercises like this are
only comical when we ignore that all of
its features are drawn directly from
actually existing proposals and
practices in the real world including
the use of facial images to predict
criminality by deliberately and
inventively upsetting the status quo in
this manner analysts can better
understand and expose the many forms of
discrimination embedded in and enabled
by technology as it turns out and I hear
I'm starting to wrap up the process of
refashioning the relationship between
race and tech Mantell actual fashion -
labs an international team of women of
color is experimenting with a wide array
of subversive designs including earrings
for recording police altercations and
visors and other clothing that prevent
facial recognition all part of they're
not safest [ __ ] project NSA F which also
stands for neuro speculative afro
feminism taken together we come to
appreciate the creative even beautiful
dimensions of resistance one of the most
comprehensive initiatives I know of is
design justice towards an intersectional
feminist framework for design theory and
practice which includes principles and
practices that central all those who are
most adversely impacted by design
decisions as we imagine and build the
world we need to live in one that is
safe and just and finally I want to
return to the important role of
insiders as movement builders and let
you know about one of the many
opportunities to get involved this
Friday night in San Francisco ACL u--'s
Kate Crawford and AI now's Meredith
Whitaker will be speaking about their
technology for liberty program the
framing of the event quote reclaiming
the future reminds me of Angela y
Davis's caution dangerous limits have
been placed on the very possibility of
imagining alternatives these ideological
limits have to be contested we have to
begin to think in different ways our
future is at stake the task then as I
see it is not only to resist the new gym
code but to work with others to imagine
and build alternatives as part of a
larger struggle to materialize
collective freedoms and flourishing and
as this final article published by
science for the people reminds us
contrary to popular narratives
organizing among technical workers has a
vibrant history including engineers and
technicians in the 60s and 70s who
fought professionalism individualism and
reformed ism to contribute to radical
labor organizing the current tech
workers movement can draw from these
past organizers strategies and
challenges and learning to navigate the
contradictions and complexities of
organizing and tech today so if as I've
suggested at the start the carceral
imagination captures and contains that
an abolitionist imagination opens up
possibilities and pathways it creates
new templates and builds on critical
intellectual and activist traditions
that have continually developed insights
and strategies grounded in justice thank
you for your attention
[Applause]
that's my provocation when we get to the
discussion
[Music]
[Music]
all right if we're having me
say did not expect to see a better off
Ted reference this morning I think that
you and I might be the only people who
ever watched that show but I've seen it
five times I guess that gets us six
people it's an amazing TV series I don't
know if you've seen it it's really good
and that pert in fact I I'm almost
certain that if I were just not to give
my talk and just show that five-minute
YouTube clip probably you'll have better
experience but I'm not that generous so
we can yeah we should I have a cued up I
have it cued up oh wow this is just
gonna be yeah I throw down I guess we'll
see who has a better YouTube connection
I guess so let me just walk through a
little bit what I thought I'd do is kind
of come at it almost narrative Lee
so if parts of my talk now appear naive
its
I think the autobiographical naivete
that appears when you start in an area
and you start to develop in it so I'm
just gonna kind of walk through
autobiographically how I got into this
literature and then try and end you with
where I think I am now so the story
starts 20-something years ago don't
worry it's not that long story
but it does start 20-something years ago
but my first real experience working in
discrimination was this project I did
with my collaborator Marianne Bertrand
where we had read this book by Richard
Nisbett a culture of honor just a
amazing book one of the great books of
social science is a book about a fairly
narrow topic which is the culture of
honor in the South what it makes it
amazing is it's a methodological
tour-de-force he uses every tool that I
could possibly imagine to understand and
unpack the culture of Honor if you want
to read just an amazing social science
book
is it one of the things he does in one
chapter to understand the culture or
longer he's that he does this little
study where he sends out resumes for
jobs and he says in the resume he
includes a cover letter in which either
this is all in the south it's all whites
but and in which the person on the
resume has been to jail for I believe
manslaughter and either the person
simply says oh I you know I did this
time I've served my time I've you know
I've become a better person or the
person says something to the effect of
the person was sleeping with my wife I
had to do it it was you know but
whatever whatever and so he's testing
this culture of Honor do we get more
callbacks if you include that paragraph
then if you simply just said I've done
my time and he has a set of studies like
this that's simply beautiful
but Maryann had a brilliant insight
she's like why can't we use this to test
other things and in particular why can't
we use this not just in the south not
just with whites but to simply just test
how big is racism and in the labor
market
so her idea was that we send resumes
thousands and thousands of employers
that was a time when many of you who I
see there are young people in the
audience we sent them using these things
called fax machines it's kind of like
email but would make more sound and the
sorry and use up paper yeah we should
show them what paper is this might be a
thing where we're really going down a a
really tangled path here I should just
stick to this talk so we would send out
these resumes and before sending them
out we had you know that we had a whole
machinery before sending them out we
would simply randomize what was the name
on the resume would it be Brendan Miller
which is a typical white name or would
it be Jamal Jones a typical black name
and then we had phone booths set
where we would take call it was a
complicated thing but we would end up
knowing what was the callback rate so
what was interesting about this study
I'll just give this one side note when
you do empirical work it's often
fascinating because it's the time you
confront reality like you just have no
idea what you will find because the data
will be the data you've set up the
experiment now you'll measure and I
don't know what I thought I would find
I'm really not sure I think I suspect
that I would find a big gap the
direction I thought I would find a big
gap is less callbacks for
african-americans but while doing this
study and designing it to make sure the
resumes were real how we would make them
real I talked to a lot of HR managers
and HR managers are by construction a
liberal group of people by and large it
might not be known man HR management and
a lot of companies tend to lean very
left many of them were from various
minority groups or were women I mean so
is a pretty left and many of them said
oh you're going to find in this study a
gap for sure but it will be the favored
Jamal that that really perturbed me
because I started this study I mean we
thought we but I was like wow what what
do I do if we find a gap in the other
day I don't I guess that's the gap we
show the gap that's it yet here are
these people who do the job telling me
that's what I was gonna find because
they said look our problem is finding
qualified african-american candidates
you're sending me qualified
african-american heads you don't
understand in our process all the work
we put into it to find qualified
african-american candidates
it was a funny we're gonna run this
study for a year and it was a funny
three to six month period but at some
point it became clear we didn't need to
run it for a year because the gap was so
big it was showing up in a month the gap
was strikingly large for those of you
who haven't worked with this kind of
social science data you might think this
is not large but I'll walk you through
why it's just insanely big so the
callback rate for white names was about
8.5%
the callback rate for black names was
about six point one nine percent which
is lower and one way you can think about
it is oh wait that's just two point
three something percentage points but in
fact the way you should think about it
is if a white person and a
african-american or a black person was
sending out resumes at the same rate
they just gotten unemployed this gap
divided tells you how much longer their
unemployment spell will be the lesser
discussed part of this thing which is
something I want to highlight here
because it is easy to overlook it's also
the it's gonna sound fairly solipsistic
to say one of the main takeaways I had
in this let paper was that you can only
have one fact in a paper people always
remember this fact but they don't
remember what I thought of as the
crucial fact for some reason no one
takes that away I don't know why but
there it is which is we also did a
design where we sent out low-quality
resumes and high-quality resumes this is
a two-by-two design and in that design
we saw that oh sorry
we saw that actually up tried the
slightest poorly animated you'll notice
that when the resume gets good it goes
from eight point five to ten point seven
nine for whites pretty good return to
skill blacks get basically no return to
skill in fact I don't have it here but
we did this thing where every employer
got four resumes black high-skill white
high-skill black low-scale white
low-skill so you can actually work out
the combinatorial of the distribution of
what got called so many people called
only the white high-skilled may need
other people called only the white
high-skilled and the white low-skilled
then they got down to the black
high-skilled so you can even see the
reveal preference for the ranking which
to me is an even bigger indictment
because it says it's not just about the
gap but about the process of human
decision-making somehow dismiss not just
the resume but the skill in the resume a
beautiful study came out about two years
three years ago so time flies about four
years ago I think now in the American
Economic Review which actually redid
something like this study but they
actually sent out the resumes and people
would come to the to the website to read
the resume and they did tracking and
what they found was when there was a
white name people would scroll further
down but when there was a black name
they wouldn't even scroll down so the
process involves not seeing the higher
skill yeah so people have done that yet
so this study was crude in some ways
because with unfortunately not yeah
unfortunately it's not been the case
that people who have tried other stimuli
have actually found it it is something
we have to confront which is I think the
HR managers after this study came out
they were genuinely perplexed they had a
process that they were sure was seeking
out these candidates in good faith at
least that set of people who I talked to
perhaps naively I felt that they're
acting on good faith not I can't say
they were not in this study but given
that we randomly sampled you know firms
they were like the firm's in this study
maybe there was a difference but but yes
it in effect that's the assumption I'm
operating on
someone else does that yeah I mean
tonight
well explicitly is funny you're reading
through four hundred resumes really fast
yeah fair enough you noticed who the
person is we've done a bunch of lab
studies where we've I mean it it seems
different people have done it in
countries where pictures are standard
par for the course and you're looking at
groups that are not that and you find
the same effects that's been pretty
striking it's very hard to do here
because it's hard to send pictures for
this category of job it's just not
standard par for the course but it's if
I were to look at now many many people
have done these studies if I were to
look across it initially when we first
did it one key question was is the name
stimuli key and having seen all of it
no one's really found name stimuli to be
that central to this activity though in
this context I'm not up to date on the
literature I can show you one other
study that next which I was going to
yeah I know you mentioned that because
HR is female and left and diverse that
it's surprising to see this I think it's
probably worth mentioning that studies
that have tried to delineate this based
on gender women are worse at at being
generous to high qualified women in
certain in certain similar studies done
on women and men so it's not it's not
enough to say like this but not when
they're called out I don't know in other
words if you pointed out that community
so that's why I'm saying that the
picture that would be most probably at
home yeah and everyone was willing to
let her not keep going yeah I'm sorry
yeah this is I don't even gotten to what
I was gonna did you yeah and then I can
just an endeavour pager has review
articles that he's done and done not
only around employment but also around
house
other kinds of institutional measures
and pictures actually make things worse
not better and that's also proud of the
premise of the implicit association test
how people respond to pictures versus
names so I would highly recommend cuz
Deborah did some of these early studies
as well doing the sending out the
resumes and the comparisons she passed
away this past year but but I would
recommend looking up any of it because
she's done the systematic review of the
literature to see what's actually
happening again discrimination in
relation and also with the tests around
criminality and all the rest being put
in the resume but in relation to housing
and also employment and other
institutional settings as well yeah I
think Davis study also involved
these are resumes they've also her
primary method involved having people go
for interviews so there's a later stage
if I'm say but but there's a later stage
in which there is in fact interview type
audits which then also get you further
into the process any other question yeah
I was just going to say there's also
research that shows that once had
from the HR perspective that instead of
challenging your assumptions and
implicit bias you had the training that
you're like this okay so when I took
away from this experience was it's sort
of a great deal of humility because I
think the people who at least some of
the people are responsible for these
processes things were happening in those
processes that they themselves didn't
fully understand and I think that that
is a common theme and most of the work
that I have done social systems are just
incredibly complicated and we can
imagine we understand them and we can
imagine that we say oh I know what is
happening but it's just there's not a
study I've done where I'm not just super
surprised I will say that there's many
audits like this done in many contexts
and I'll just conclude this bit by
saying you know just so you can see how
extreme this is there's sort of been
hundreds of studies like this
davus review articles good Betty Levy
palek and Marianne have another review
article on field experiments in
discrimination last year or two but this
is an example of where you can see how
pernicious it is this is people who are
selling iPods on eBay and so in this
study the author's basically simply just
sold a bunch of iPods on eBay
and in one condition they had white
hands holding the iPod I mean the
usernames were meaningless but the hands
are clear in another condition they had
black hands holding and in another
condition they had white hands with
tattoos
for reasons that still seem a bit
mysterious to me but nevertheless that
was the design and what you find is that
with the white hands the sales rate is
around 3.8 percent with the black hand
sorry with the white hands with head
don't get tattoos about 3 percent but a
huge drop with black hand it's quite
striking so there are just an quite a
quite an endless supply of these studies
at this point where the method is to
probe the social system with human
decision-makers on a variety of fronts
fronts sort of probe it almost as
non-invasively as possible and to shine
characterize its bias from which I would
take away that human bias whatever its
Genesis I think one hypothesis has been
floated that's become popular and people
use the phrase implicit bias is that
these are implicit biases and that's a
that's a very distinct likely possibly
possible but as I said if we approach it
with the humility I would say the the
fact we know is huge amounts of bias in
the system
almost every stage and most audits
attended that did the exception and the
interesting exception our audits that
tend not to find bias and those gets
published as well and we can talk about
them and they're kind of noteworthy for
what they are so that's phase one phase
two about six years ago Mike few my
co-authors notably Yin's Ludwig and
raised and brought up he works a lot in
crime he said look each year there are
about 12 million arrests in the US right
after arrest there is a big decision the
big decision is would the person spend
the time between arrests and trial in
jail or would they spend it at home this
is an incredibly consequential decision
one way to understand its consequence is
to understand the scale of impact
there are approximately 750,000 people
in jail in the United States so and the
distinction I had not appreciated is the
difference in the work jail in the word
prison majority of the vast majority
people in jail are people waiting for
trial you're sent to prison largely when
you've been convicted largely you sit in
jail when you're waiting so that means
about a third of the incarcerated
population in the United States these
are rough numbers our people so at
anymore in time if you said here's of an
incarcerated person it's a person who's
simply waiting they have not been found
guilty of anything they're simply just
in sort of a holding pen so to speak
that person is going to be there
actually for a long time in most
jurisdictions the average length of stay
in that holding pen is two to three
months there are many jurisdictions
where the average stay is nine to twelve
months as a result for many crimes
that's why the sentence is time served
even if you are found guilty because
people are some way and the the
consequential decision I just want it
without passing judgment I just want to
point out how I think most let's say
judges would argue how they view the
trade-off okay so the trade-off is hey
if a person comes in and I let them go
home and they commit a crime like that's
on me I've like now actually had a
person in there they committed the crime
conversely if the judge keeps them in
jail think of the enormous consequences
for that person and their family and
their future your job is gone in fact
studies careful causal inference studies
of jail have shown huge effects because
you do not keep your job if you're in
jail for two to three months and it is
just a heavily loaded decision on both
sides of the coin
okay so that's the problem I think he
ends it had raised was there a question
in the back did you sorry no no yes yeah
yeah this is pretrial detention yet it's
not crime it's pretrial detention so
start here yeah yeah
yes this is conditional on car serration
yeah I might be wrong but we can happily
talk but yeah okay so when we think
about this problem the problem that I
typically tend to think of is that
african-americans and Hispanics are more
likely to be white discriminated against
in this system
these are perceptions 72% you know
perceptions of bias even amongst white
Americans they're some pretty high forty
percent of people saying this is a
pretty biased system it also studies
which are not audit studies but which
are very interesting studies is one of
my favorite ones which is striking and
striking it uses the fact that there is
random assignment into jury pools
effectively so so who happens to be in
the pool at that moment determines who's
in years as a result in certain
jurisdictions you can get almost by
random whether your jury has a black
person in it or not and it's striking
the difference in conviction rates is 81
versus 66% if there's the presence of a
black person in your jury make sure I
get this right sorry no 81 percent
conviction rate for blacks sixty-six
percent conviction rates for whites if
you include a black person the number of
drops is 71 and 73
so I misspoke this is all white curious
this is a jury that have at least one
but very striking you can see the extent
this is this is an intent to treat type
thing so you create we can get into the
machinery of it but you create a random
assignment to a potential then when you
go and do the inference you account for
the fact that not all potential
translates into real so that's the this
is sort of in the lingo of it you would
think of as local average treatment
effect so you're not just doing raw
differences you okay so when I come back
to this problem I approach this with
sort of a human bias approach and from
that point of view if you ask what is
the judge asked to do by law what they
are supposed to be doing means they're
supposed to be taking the defendant
history and I put the word crime here
you could put light risk public safety
risk and the states vary in the law but
the judge in determining this pretrial
decision is supposed to be taking into
account a future prediction about public
safety risk or flight risk and they're
not supposed to be taking into account
anything else that is not did you commit
the crime that you committed that is at
least what they're supposed to be doing
and what's strange about this activity
coming from a psychology point of view
is that it looks like a magnified
version of a resume study but done like
but everything I've understood about HR
managers I'm like so you're really
telling me some judge he's gonna look at
this person even see them and then form
an unbiased estimate of flight risk and
public safety risk this just seems like
craziness so at that point in this story
what we thought was hey we've got all
this data we could actually take this
data we've got millions of this and form
an algorithm or a statistical object
that converted this to this
now what I'm going to try to do is to
tell you what happened when we formed
that algorithm do that and what we find
is here's here's the first thing we did
we said let's simply rank people by the
risk as predicted by the algorithm and
then what the algorithm can do is say if
you want to release 10% here is the
algorithmic judgment of risk and risky
is 1020 riskiest 30 so at every release
rate you've got something that implies a
crime rate we'll come back to what that
word crime means given how I thought
importantly careful the previous
speakers were on highlighting what that
word means we'll come back to that cuz
that's going to be crucial to the story
but here at every release rate what
crime rate do we get this is what the
algorithm produces and for us since we
entered into this as judges potentially
show a lot of bias we wanted to compare
the judge to the algorithm so how do we
do that what we seen since we don't know
where we want to be on this curve what
we can do is we can say well judges
currently are choosing the release 73.7%
of people at that particular rate the
algorithm produces an 8.5% crime rate if
we held those constant then what we
would see is that at the same release
rate we get at the jogger in produces
eight-point-five the judge had produced
11.3 so it feels like a 24% reduction in
crime I'll be honest with you that is
not the personally interesting to me
what was really interesting to me was
gee if you are willing to live with
11.3% crime in the current environment
great the algorithm at least eighty four
point six percent of people so we can
drop the jail populations by 40 percent
I think before we get into the question
of racial bias there is something
important here which I think we have to
understand suppose for now we're not
going to get there but suppose we think
this tool is gonna be implemented
whether whether we go from where we are
now seventy-three point six percent in
this much crime down hey let's keep jail
populations the same and simply just
reduce crime or whether we go that way
makes a huge difference if we go that
way
forty percent fewer in jail is a pretty
big reduction of the jail populations
this was all done in New York and so my
co-author yen's would would often refer
to this as you could close Rikers in
July that's roughly what forty percent
is I haven't tested the math and maybe
with the ends involved I should be
testing the math but I think July is
sixty percent of the way through the
year and so linking back I guess using
the new language there's a little bit of
rewriting I would say this could be a
tool for abolition really and one way to
think about it before we get to racial
bias is that the qualitative evidence we
have with judges is that they and and I
think Martha you mentioned this at some
point - they have exaggerated fears of
the actual flight and public safety risk
so potentially what this thing could be
picking up is the rates are much lower
than you think
a flight risk and public safety risk you
think 50 percent it is not fifty percent
and that's one arrow that this gives us
in our quiver but let's now ask how does
this affect african-americans or
Hispanics so the first observation I
want to make is that I had approached
this problem I think at that time very
differently than it turned out the
literature had approached it the first
thing that I thought was not through the
lens of the relative bias of the
algorithm but through the absolute
disparate impact of reducing jail
populations as the first order thing we
should look at if you take a thing jail
which is disproportionately African
American and you lower its rate by 40%
that's who it's gonna benefit the most
so when you have Rikers having 57
percent african-american and 85 percent
minorities if we could go in that
direction that is a big gain and I don't
think that's the complete picture but I
would say that's still an important part
of the picture that sometimes lost in
these conversations we asked the
relative ranking without thinking about
the huge disparate benefit one way or
the other you can have the right
relative ranking and raised jail
populations and the first order of fact
is your jailing more people you can have
you know slight things off in the
relative and reduce oh it's just this
effect is really I think of first order
if you do the quantitative calculation
it but having said that I think we
should move to the relative so I'll do
that so disparate benefit of reductions
in jail populations the absolute
benefits can be lost I really don't want
to lose them in the relative questions
and both should at least be discussed
the second thing I wanted to get to is
there's this algorithm target
african-americans really like I think
when people look at this I heard I just
was so miscalibrated
everyone the first time I presented this
everyone's intuition was this algorithm
would target African Americans and mine
was not sorry the one we built yeah
and I understood why my intuition was so
different from everyone else's my
intuition in fact for example the
algorithm doesn't reconstruct race the
reason my intuition was that why would
we think it does I had come in thinking
the average african-american in jail was
less criminogenic than the average white
in jail so if anything it should be
reconstructing it to let them out
there's an arbitrage opportunity created
by human bias and that arbitrage
opportunity is that whatever you decide
about the underlying variable even if we
dislike the crime variable the at the
extra bias added by judges in their
decision-making means that even by the
original flawed measure the average
black is better in that measure than the
average way that's the bias term so in
fact that's a second lesson I kind of
point now it does find it so we can kind
of talk a little about to the extent
which it gets it a little bit and where
does it get it from so the relative
impacts actually when we went to look at
them are fairly minor so there's a 31
percent black detention rate for judge
there's roughly at 32 percent you kind
of get it to go both ways the final
lesson we had from working on this
project was what fools we were we
actually didn't tell the algorithm we
cared about this we simply just
optimized one objective function so we
should have built an algorithm that says
we're not going to just look at total
crime rate or incarceration rate we care
about both variables when you do that
what you actually find is you can get a
27% detention detention rate for blacks
and the exact same crime drop so you can
dramatically drop and end up with much
lower detention rates while still
getting the same crime gains and this is
just by way of saying it is a
mathematical point I'm going to make now
but it's an important mathematical point
there if you look at the marginal black
defendant if you know you would like to
drive down crime
in particular groups the algorithm needs
to optimize for finding those
individuals if it if it just views that
as one other variable and wouldn't one
other thing it can't optimize for that
but when you optimize you actually find
a huge terrain as you would expect from
human bias of low risk even by this
faulty measure african-americans that
you could just release and you say if
that's what you care about here here is
the predictor now let me close that this
NL and now by saying can we trust our
output outcome after all crime is
determined by the same human biases that
we fear it's worth noting that similar
effects appear for failure to appear
rather than real rest which we can think
about what that means it's also worth
noting though that there are bigger
effects for murder rape and robbery that
has bigger gains for murder rape and
robbery and that's notable for me
because the literature on bias in
policing starts to become very
complicated and murky when we get to
crimes like murder rape and robbery when
you look at net a victim ization surveys
and you look at the victim race and you
look at the arrest rates in say
geographic areas it's it becomes hard to
know which direction the bias of
policing goes is it higher rates
conditional on on something happening or
is it in fact lower rates because these
areas are over policed but also under
police it's as if a lot of crimes in
these areas are largely ignored by the
police so I don't know what to make for
how well we can trust our outcome having
said that I kind of would conclude the
whole thing by saying whatever you think
of the crime thing even if you don't
trust in it if you think the other side
of the conversation does you have a
quiver in your arrow to say look we can
keep your crime rate the same way you
want and drop your jailing rate by this
much that so that's one one small
positive thing I've taken away from this
so now let me close by saying how do I
compare this to what the both previous
speakers talked about with what is
clearly a crappy out
the public algorithm why is anything
we've done different from what they've
done there's a salient difference I
don't think it has anything to do with
our technical skills I think it has to
do with I have no idea what compass does
and no one does likely not even the
makers of compass why do I say that
because there's a fundamental evaluation
problem I sort of kind of gone over and
Aleks has worked a lot on this problem
which is how how are we to know how the
algorithm does on the jail the
population like unless you do a lot of
work we don't have data on those who are
jailed so you can do work but I
seriously doubt the people accomplice
have we don't know what was the
objective being maximized by the compass
makers if you said to me what was the
data used yeah as an economist I could I
could I could I could I should say
profit having worked with enough
medium-sized firms I'm not really sure
what they're doing but yes let's I'll
try to keep my economist fees in say
profit what was the data used was there
a holdout set put aside everything about
algorithmic bias can anyone even say
with any confidence for the narrow
objective of pretty predicting rehearsed
does compass do better than random
I would like to know that question it's
hard to know so to me the challenge is
that algorithms can be used yeah there
were these work by Sharat girls group on
showing even if you know all these
things you know the data you know the
features you know the algorithm unity of
X function you get the same trade-offs
and so the same concerns would stand so
let's compare well how would you compare
your thing to it's an area where you
know all these things but the same
trade-off well so the algorithm we
construct that we know all these things
and so we're the I'm saying is nothing
like an answer like Sharad does this
work we said well we can we can build
these things in a way that you haven't
answered to all these questions but you
think with these two the same trade-off
that were pointed out yeah we're way
over time let me just get to this later
yeah thank you yeah thank you for
calling it yeah
thank you so let me come back yet so I'd
say that algorithms I'm conclude on this
algorithms can be used maliciously for a
great deal of harm using the same words
I might use and that's what I took away
from the contrast with ProPublica and
the devil is really in the details and
to me where I'll try to conclude is the
challenge seems far more sociological
than technical which is how do you
create a far more sophisticated I'm
using word consumers which I'll come
back to the next slide and I'll stop
because this really is about the fact
that there is this new tool that if that
it can do great harm great but it's not
clear what it's going to be doing and
whether you are a sophisticated
participant in the construction and
consumption of that tool or an
unsophisticated participant seems to be
the entire difference in all this so
I'll skip where we go next in the
interest of time and I'll just conclude
on this in the next slide some early
lessons is that you know I say it sort
of algorithmic bias has to talk about
human bias and I have to be very precise
about the counterfactual and maybe
that's the answer to
to your questions what I really took
away is the problem is not in the
algorithms but in the social process
that is dictating how algorithms are
procured scrutinized and evaluated and
I'd like to think where I am now
is that there are people out there using
them for harm I would like to try to use
them for good and how are we going to do
that and I think the way I'm currently
thinking about it is to do that we have
to do a lot more piloting and measuring
and judging of whether the thing is
working but all of that has to be done
in public and that seems to me the most
useful thing I've gotten out of
interacting with this literature is just
everyone can stress test every
assumption and and go to that so ok I'll
stop there sorry for running over time
[Applause]
ok